I'm an eye surgeon from Bowling Green
Kentucky I'm the son of an Irish Italian
mom I brought my own water my story from
secretary to CEO is only possible in
this nation by the way I think I
actually flew on this plane with Ronald
Reagan first of all Rand Paul shouldn't
even be on this stage the one guy that
had some special interests that I know
of
that tried to get me to change my views
on something that was generous and gave
me money was Donald Trump he wanted
casino gambling in Florida yes you did
one second no I did not take more energy
tonight I like that I in no way am
willing to get into bed with special
interest groups or lick the boots of
billionaires I will rip to shreds this
catastrophic Iranian nuclear deal we cut
up the agreement immediately that's
absurd when you want to know if they've
complied I was the one of the first ones
to call for terminating the bad deal
with Iran on day one I think she's got a
beautiful face and I think she's a
beautiful woman
Donald Trump's being in this race has
forced the mainstream media finally to
talk about illegal immigration to his
all due respect mr. Trump we have been
talking about illegal immigration for 25
years Carly listen get it through up to
everybody else in this stage I threw up
me I've been listening everybody on this
stage and there's a lot of
back-and-forth about I'm the only one
who's done this the only one who's done
that I've done great things
we've all done great things so we
wouldn't be on this stage don't worry
about me and Hillary that all work out
and I'm from Ohio she will not beat me
there I can promise you that
you see Governor Christie people spend a
lot of time talking about their track
record Arab name Arab name as a relates
to my brother there's one thing I know
for sure he kept us safe I suggested to
President Bush that he not go to war
okay so I just want that on the record
there will always be a bush or Clinton
for you if you want to go back to war in
Iraq we need about 50 army brigades we
need about 36 marine battalions we need
somewhere between 300 and 350 naval
ships it is true that after George W
Bush nominated John Roberts I supported
his confirmation that was a mistake and
I regret that so 40 years ago I smoked
marijuana's and I admit it I'm sure that
other people might have done it and may
not want to say it on front of 25
million people my mom's not happy that I
just did America is not a planet I
wouldn't change the $10 bill or the $20
bill you know I've been I've been called
a lot of names by a lot of different
people and now I gotta get called
financed by the Secret Service I would
just say true heart ever ready it's very
high-energy Donald humble